mais pour en parler de cette rentrée
nous sommes avec arno fabre
administrateur national du collectif les
styles en rouge bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
beaucoup dans le milieu de l'éducation a
pris ce protocole annoncé par jean
michel blanquer dans la presse
précisément dans le jdd dimanche à ce
que c'est c'est votre cas aussi ça veut
dire qu'il n'y a pas eu de consultation
ah non tout à fait il n'y a pas eu de
consultation et il n'y a eu au mieux que
quelques informations envoyées aux
organisations professionnelles
organisations syndicales et
effectivement le biais le plus fréquent
pour jean michel blanquer c'est de
communiquer via la presse alors le jdd
surtout en ligne dans la partie réservée
aux abonnés bon pour communiquer avec
les 1 million 200 mille personnel qui
travaille dans l'éducation nationale
plus les familles des 13 millions
d'élèves je trouve que vraiment c'est
prendre cette rentrée la légère et
surtout pour la plupart un des
professeurs c'est une rentrée qui va se
faire sous le signe malheureusement de
la résignation pourquoi parce que cette
rentrée en fait elle se fait que c'est
la deuxième rentrée avec le co vide et
ce sera la troisième année scolaire
concerné par le cos vide et encore une
fois nous sommes dans une improvisation
dans une impréparation totale
tout simplement parce que de toute façon
on le sait jean michel blanquer est
vraiment l'homme du déni ans et le petit
bol sonar aux français celui pour qui
finalement balocco vide c'est quelque
chose qui doit rapidement passé 1 et
surtout pour qu'on reprenne les choses
comme si rien ne s'était produit un on
ne va surtout pas changer 1 ce qui se
passe dans les classes nous demandons de
goran changement et c'est maintenant
qu'il faut lui alors effectivement un
protocole retenu pour la rentrée on nous
dit que c est celui du niveau de cours
en présentiel
notamment dans les écoles collèges et
lycées masque obligatoire à l'intérieur
dès la primaire limitation du brassage
par niveau et aération renforcée c'est
vrai qu'il ya pas un changement majeur
vous espériez plus
c'est pour ça que je parlais de
résignation je crois que la plupart de
nos collègues espérait surtout une prise
de conscience une prise de conscience du
fait que enfin le ministre de
l'éducation mais aussi bien sur les plus
hautes autorités de l'état c'est à dire
monsieur macro le président de la
république avec est aidé par son conseil
scientifique se rend compte que oui
l'école est un véritable lieu de
contamination ce sont des choses que
l'on sait sont des choses qui sont
établis scientifiquement
or malheureusement c'est justement cet
écart entre bien sûr les annonces et la
réalité mais cet écart surtout entre la
réalité scientifique et sur les
solutions qui sont proposées regarder on
nous propose un seul niveau le niveau 2
pour l'ensemble dû territoire
métropolitain
c'est complètement absurde haut depuis
la crise le début de la crise due qu'aux
villes à de nombreuses reprises les
décisions étaient territorialisée les
niveaux d' alerte et les décisions
c'est-à-dire et ouvertures de classes
notamment après le premier grand
confinement ont été faites en ce sens
donc encore une fois je crois que là il
faut absolument des choses simples à
mettre en place mais qui nécessite aussi
des moyens et des moyens vous parliez
tout à l'heure dans le précédent
reportage d'une politique de relance par
l'investissement
l'école est la grande oubliée de cet
investissement il fallait le faire au
niveau des postes pourquoi parce qu'il
faut dédoubler les classes c'est à dire
des doubles et c'est à dire faire des
2000 groupe enfin la charge concernant
vraiment ce protocole sanitaire
jean-michel bancaire vous savez à
écarter un ce concours au pass
sanitaires pour les professeurs les
élèves et les parents d'élèves vous
auriez souhaité qu'ils instaurent
c'était 7 s p table justement dans ce
contexte à risque que vous nous décrivez
ce qui est souhaitable surtout c'est de
prendre le risque tel qu'il est
actuellement on le sait liv ce fameux
variant guelta contamine essentiellement
les jeunes et comme on le sait on l'a
entendu à de nombreuses reprises la
nature a horreur du vide elle va vers
ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés c'est à
dire vers les enfants à partir de là il
fallait absolument que on met en place
tout de suite notamment des capteurs de
co2 tout simplement pour prendre on peut
dire la température du risque mais là
sans jouer sur les mots ça sera un gros
risque pour le ministre de se rendre
compte que scientifiquement et bien dans
les classes les contaminations en lieu
il fallait aussi des purificateurs d'air
alors ça effectivement ça coûte cher
c'est un non non non pas du tout non non
non pas du tout les capteurs de co2 ont
été recommandées mais il n'y a pas les
financements contrairement à nous d'être
bons oui mais alors justement qu'est-ce
qu'une aération renforce on va éviter
d'amener l'affairé n'est pas encore mal
et bien c'est ça que vous propose jean
michel blanquer donc à un moment donné
je crois que des données
scientifiquement établie il faut que les
ars en voit dans les 400 à 500 mille
salles de classe des gens vraiment
rapidement pour prendre la mesure du
risque à partir de là voir si l'aération
peut se faire s'il ne peut pas se faire
il faut mettre en place immédiatement en
fonction si du taux d'incidence est bien
il faut mettre en place les deux mines
groupe pour parce que c'est faisable
parce que c'est souhaitable et parce que
sinon il y aura comme l'institut pasteur
le prédit un de manière la scientifique
ce ne sont pas des mages dans ce faux
pas des diseuses de bonne aventure et
l'institut pasteur prédisent 50000
contamination par jour chez les jeunes
dès la mi ou la fin septembre il faut
donc empêché absolument une cinquième
bague ou ça il faut soit changé de
ministre sans que lui ma dernière
question à nos fans pas la moindre
puisque jean michel blanquer a annoncé
qu'une campagne de vaccination débutera
dès la rentrée scolaire pour les élèves
de plus de 12 ans qui le souhaitent on
sait qu'il ya beaucoup de doutes de
réticences et les parents même si plus
de 55 % des adolescents sont déjà
vaccinés d'une dose vous comprenez ses
parents ou au contraire il faut
justement renforcer ses campagnes de
vaccination est allé dans ce sens là
la question de la vaccination est une
question de santé publique moi je suis
professeur de français je ne me
prononcerai pas sur ces questions ce qui
est très important c'est qu'il faut
protéger les populations or comme la
plupart des contaminations étaient
kloster selon santé publique france ont
lieu dans le cadre scolaire
contrairement à ce que dit le ministre
je le répète soit il faut changer de
ministres qui se conduit comme un
imposteur soit alors il faut des
décisions fermes et notamment dans les
zones les plus contaminées le sud de la
france et l'île de france merci à tous
car nos favre d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france